yes he certainly is a miracle baby and
he's actually a lifesaver as well
because without my desire to have him I
probably wouldn't be here so he's very
special
so explain that to me why do you say
that tell us a little bit about what
you've been through
so I I've always wanted to be a mummy
I've known it since I've been little so
when back in 2017
um I was focusing on my career and knew
that I did want to be a mummy but career
came first at that moment in time but
then I started to get a very sharp pain
in my appendix area which transpired
that it was my appendix bursting and
then I started to get some um
sharp some dull sorry some dull pains in
my appendix and then some spotting in
between my periods which kind of made me
think something's not quite right here
and the only reason I thought that was
because I wanted to be a mummy I then
went to the GP and then fast forward
five months I was then referred to the
Christie and met Bex here and that's
when my cancer Journey really kicked in
and took took shape really yes so tell
us Rebecca a bit about this cancer
because it was quite a rare form of
cancer that Stacy had wasn't it
it's very rare yes it affects one to two
per million population per year it's
called pseudomexoma Survivor at
pseudomyxoma peritoneal or PMP for the
shortening and it starts in the appendix
it's a tumor that spreads very
um slowly through the appendicial wall
and around the abdominal and pelvic
cavity it doesn't go into the organs and
It Coats the organs and patients tend to
present with a distended tummy
yeah and and so when you had that
diagnosis Stacy it must have been
devastating for you on on many fronts
not least because you were so Keen to be
a mother but you did have your eggs
Harvester didn't you
did yes so
um when I was told that my ovaries would
have to go that was a huge blow to me
but luckily
um because the disease is slow growing I
had a bit of time in between the first
and second operation and I managed to
get two rounds of egg harvesting in
which I am so grateful for and I managed
to get 17 eggs
um which then resulted in two embryos
which then resulted in Harry which is
just absolutely fantastic news and how
are you doing as far as the cancer is
concerned Stacy
fingers crossed touch wood five years
clear this year
um it's my anniversary in August oh
fantastic so much to celebrate there and
and obviously for you Rebecca really
pleasing to just to have caught this
cancer given that it's rare that it was
properly diagnosed and treated
um yeah I mean it's just incredible news
that we got hold of Stacey at the very
beginning of her journey so that made
things um a lot easier and better for
Stacey
um it meant we could treat the cancer
from the beginning and she had the exact
right treatment which is why she's here
today and doing so fantastically well
and I have to say you do let the picture
of Happiness as they see there with with
Harry explain to us um what it means to
you to be able to be standing there
holding your baby
the absolute world he is amazing and
he's totally turned my world upside down
definitely life is now for living lots
of Adventures and lots of fun with
friends and family as well of supporting
us so all very exciting